welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down episode 8 of The Last of
Us this is the one I've been waiting for
and David in the games one of the most
memorable characters that you come
across when playing Voice by Nolan North
he started off as an apparent Ally but
as you began to learn more about him you
start to see his more Sinister side
though blow those clickers in the
infected were terrifying I think one of
the scariest things for me was playing
as Ellie and moving about the restaurant
as he walked around wielding a machete
normally Boss characters and games are
gigantic monsters or highly skilled
characters there was just something so
unnerving about a creepy 50 year old
cannibal walking around looking for you
now as is with all Last of Us episodes
the fact that we aren't playing the game
means that they can show things from the
perspective of others in the PlayStation
counterpart you will lock to the POV of
Joel and Ali or as here we can see more
of David's backstory that's how we begin
as well and we open by looking over his
town which is called Silver Lake in both
the Sean game we discover David has
taken it upon himself to become a holy
man and over the top of this we hear him
narrating Revelation 21. his opening
line discusses the new Heaven and new
earth and this very much reflects a new
world that they've found themselves in
the midst of the verses in this chapter
talk about how there'll be no need for a
physical temple in this new world
because God's presence will be
everywhere we then jump to see him
hitched up in Todd's Steakhouse to watch
him delivering a sermon Todd's
restaurant was what it was called in the
game and it's been transformed into a
makeshift church we see how people have
tried to find reason in what's happened
to the world and you can totally
understand why someone turned to
religion I didn't want to spoil this
episode all the way back in the first
entry but it's even possible that Mrs
Adler could have foreshadowed people
going like this well that's true every
day isn't it people out there need to
get right with Jesus now religion Beyond
things spiritually also acts as a way to
explain things for example thousands of
years ago people didn't understand how
the world was formed but religions gave
these answers whilst also outlining the
best ways to live thus people flock
towards them because science hadn't
given Alternatives I'm trying to explain
this as best as possible as I can
without offending people but basically
what I'm trying to say is that in this
once more stripped back world you can
see why people would end up becoming
religious a lot of people don't have the
scientific tools to answer things and
those preachers could provide the
answers and compare to those that feel
lost now Revelations is about the end of
the world and this it's easy to see why
so many people return to this and David
after the world had ended it hasn't been
all sunshine and rainbows though and due
to long hard Winters David has had to
resort to cannibalism in order to keep
people alive you see a sign hanging up
saying when we are in need he shall
provide and this is playing on
Philippines 419 which states God will
provide for people this sign is also
pulled over to the game and when Ali
fights David in the restaurant we can
actually see this sign hanging up at the
back of the room now he's had to cross a
line in order to provide but David's
hiddenness from the people whereas in
the game I always kinda got the
impression that the townsfolk were aware
now you might be wondering why they
don't just just move somewhere warm well
the fact is that people here feel safe
and they very much control their society
they're not oppressed by Federer and the
infected also tended to stick to warmer
areas though you didn't counter some in
the snow when you first met David the
second game showed that the exposure to
the elements left them completely Frozen
you also discovered that every time they
bunker down the Raiders eventually
showed up and thus they had to find
somewhere that wasn't too appealing to
others so Salt Lake is probably the best
place to be though the cruel Winters
have meant that food becomes scarce now
interesting little tidbit for you mate
did you know that Vikings called it
Iceland because it would put Invaders
off from going there they called
Greenland that because it was covered in
ice and thus when Invaders arrived there
they'd be like sake anyway he goes to
comfort a young girl there by saying
that after pain God will make it so
there's no more sorrow we learn this
girl has just lost her father and that
they want to bury him but the ground is
too cold David calls himself her father
and it's very much a perverted version
of the dad and daughter relationship
that Joe has with Ali whereas Jill will
do anything to protect Ali David smacks
her in front of people and they're very
much surrogate fathers at opposite ends
of the scale anyway I'm getting the word
yes David is one of them and I think
that's what made the character in the
game so creepy I think this is obviously
commenting on controversies surrounding
the church and gonna be difficult not to
offend people but it's definitely an
important thing to address the entire
holy man thing with David is something
that wasn't present in the game and I
think it adds a whole new dimension to
him when he's This creepy religious
figure that eats people and prays on
children at this point we get a quick
cut of his right hand man James and in
case you don't recognize him that's Troy
Baker he actually played Joel in the
game and Baker gave this seminal
performance I think actually helped out
with a lot of the success of the last of
us he's a very beloved voice actor he's
played lots of different iconic
characters and I have to say that I
think he completely knocked it out the
park and so far in the show we've had
Marlene's voice actor playing her in the
series Tommy's popped up as Perry and
now Baker is playing James all that's
left is Ellie's Ashley Johnson so I can
imagine that she'll be popping up next
for the finale there are rumors about
who she she could be playing but will
not spoil that here should change the
name to not much of a spoiler mate like
the video anyway Baker actually looks a
lot like Childers in the game and I as
much as I love Pedro I wouldn't have
minded him playing him in live action
too look I'm not trying to offend people
again and outside we hear how dire of a
situation they're in when it comes to
rations in the game we never saw this
side of things and after Joel fell off
his horse at the University he then cut
to Ali hunting and whilst you were doing
this he noticed the bark that he then
shot an arrow in this didn't kill it
unless he tracked it through the
environment trying to take it out for
food it fled to an abandoned Factory
which is when you found it dead and at
this point James and David step forward
now here we see the other side of it
with James and David talking about how
some their spotters saw a deer the other
day you see how their paths now cross
from both sides and also explore the
doubt within James he's clearly
wrestling with the fact that they're
crossing the line in order to keep going
and adds a lot of complexity to the
character that wasn't originally there
it was pretty much just an NPC with a
couple of lines but here Baker flashes
him out so we get much more of his
thoughts now this cannibalism in the
snow could be a reference to the Donna
potty who are a group of American
Pioneers that migrated to California
from the Midwest they got stuck in a
snowy mountain range for a while and had
to resort to cannibalism like what we
see here James is starting to doubt
whether this is God's way and it's
possible he knows about the other stuff
too in the game when Joel ambushes the
town you overhearsome saying that
David's leadership should be put to a
vote again so this sentiment was clearly
felt amongst some of the other
inhabitants in the game he didn't really
encounter any of the kids here but you
did hear a woman saying that they were
moving the children to a shelter now in
the game James went off and David and
Ellie waited for him which is when they
were both sworn by infected you had to
make your way through the abandoned
Factory as they closed in and you made
your final stand against some Runners
clickers in a bloater in the game you
had no idea what was up with David at
this point and it allowed you to build
some camaraderie with him so far in the
game though he'd fought lots of hunters
the people that you'd met in cut scenes
had ended up becoming your allies this
was the case with Marlene Henry and Sam
and of course Joel's brother Tommy it
sort of lured you into this false sense
of security with him and when listening
to the kind of funny podcast a couple of
weeks ago they did bring up a point that
stuck with me since then they said that
Kathleen might have even heard that
David reveal a bit because we'd already
experienced an evil leader figure though
I don't know if that's fully the case I
do think having two characters like this
in the show hurt the fact that David was
someone you came across who was worse
than the infected you don't really trust
him from the start whereas in the game
you kind of did and I kind of feel it
missed that gut Punchy bit but let me
know below if it caught you off God this
is a public service announcement
announcement announcement manscaped have
new beard products and they're also
going further with the weed whacker 2.0
gentlemen meet the beard hedger Pro kit
it's the ultimate package that makes it
even easier to craft your signature look
it all starts with a cordless electric
beard headgear the B is tough on hairs
but smooth on your face and it has a
single stroke efficiency so you get all
those hairs with one clean stroke the
waterproof cordless trimmer has a rotary
wheel that gives you 20 hair cutting
lengths all at one guard so no more
messy drawers full of extra add-ons the
pro kit also comes with the
dermatologist tested formulations for
your post trim care this includes
manscapes beard shampoo and conditioner
beard oil and beard balm to moisturize
style and shimmy new beard plus the kit
has three free gifts it's got a beard
brush a comb and also some scissors with
a nice beard your face it's perfectly
groomed right wrong I'll tell you why
you also have those dirty nose and ear
hairs that need to get the hell out of
here the brand new weed whacker 2.0
offers improved blades and skin safe
technology with a no tugging guarantee
it's never been so painless to mind your
manholes now that you have your face
looking great you must try the manscape
4.0 performance package that now comes
with the weed whacker 2 2.0 his
significant other will be delighted that
you've covered all bases and you know
what I'm talking about so head over to
manscape.com heavy spoilers and another
code heavy spoilers at checkout for free
shipping and 20 off that's manscape.com
heavy spoilers and enter the code heavy
spoilers at checkout for 20 off and also
free shipping manscape.com heavy
spoilers heavy spoilers at the checkout
for 20 off and also free shipping cheers
now back with Ellie we see she nurses
Joel the surroundings here are identical
to the game with him being on a dirty
mattress with a couple of blankets to
keep him warm we had a shot similar to
the game where she examines his wound
and this is something she did Upon
returning from David seeing how little
food they have left I did go back and
forth over what the intention of this
scene was he does hold a snap of it for
a second and I even thought that she
might be wondering whether it's worth
giving it to him due to him being so
close to death store I don't think
that's what was intended and I'm sure
that the HBO podcast will probably clear
this up we do these videos before that's
released so I don't really get to hear
things people yeah some people genuinely
think are watching hour-long episode and
listen to a 40-minute podcast and then
make a 30 to 40 minute video and release
it the second that the show ends which
they've discovered we've been using time
travel they've figured it out
now but like I said I don't think that's
the intention and Nelly decides to mount
up and go hunting here she comes across
a rabbit like in the game and I have to
play this clip again sorry that's the
cutest [__] thing I've ever seen in
my entire life
look I'm a vegetarian yeah but still
it's a good reaction now unlike the
PlayStation counterpod Ellie's pretty
useless or as she was taking out animals
with ease in that we see here how she's
really struggling at this point she
comes across the deer and similar the
game she fails to down it we have a
moment mirroring the sniper scene from
episode 6 and I did appreciate how they
built off the back of that David and
James come across it and he does the
typical religious preacher strategy okay
all I ask is 10 seconds of your time I
just want I won't say it twice let's see
how these scenes play alongside those in
the game
[Music]
scenery
you think we can just take it
who's there
come out drop your rifles
now
hello
we just want to talk any sudden moves
and I put one right between your eyes
and he shot him moves like the arm right
between your eyes
you know for Buddy Boy ditto for Buddy
Boy over there
what do you want
name's David
this here's my friend James
we're from a larger group women children
and we're all very very hungry
from a larger group
women children
they're all very very hungry
so am I
women and children all very hungry too
well even so
you can't drag this back on your own
maybe we could do
trade you for some of that meat there
what do you need
we're not asking for charity we we can
trade you for some of the deer we have
what do you need we have medicine
weapons
ammo clothes medicine
you have any antibiotics
like for infections
we do
the camp
welcome to followers I'm not following
you anywhere
we do back in our village you're welcome
to follow us I'm not following you
anywhere
buddy boy can go get it
he comes back with what I need the deer
is all yours
buddy boy can go get it he comes back
you get half the deer anyone else shows
up you put one right between my eyes
that's right anyone else shows up I put
one word right between my eyes
that's right
two bottles of the penicillin in a
syringe make it fast
go on
bring back two bottles and a syringe
it's not code James do as I said
I'll take that rifle
people
is well aware of who Ellie is at this
point and as we later learn it was his
men that went to the university either
way they go into one of the Huts which
is similar how they camped up in the
game here we learn a bit more about
David and discover that he was a maths
teacher who converted to become a
preacher after the world fell apart not
even gonna go down the rabbit hole with
teaching avoiding that but we do learn
that he came from Pittsburgh the qz
there fell in 2017 due to a war between
the fireflies in Federer which is
something that was sort of touched upon
in the game in the show Ali and Joe went
to Kansas City whereas in the source
material that was Pittsburgh where the
whole Henry and Sam thing happened you
arrived there to find it overrun by
Bandits and could piece together enough
things to learn about what happened
Pedra had been keeping rations for
themselves and starving people and when
they were ousted the bandits rose up in
their place people like David ended up
leaving and they run into the same
problem when it comes to food the
dialogue in the scene starts to
transform into how it plays out in the
game you know you really shouldn't be
out here
I don't like company you know you really
shouldn't be out here all on your own
from where I'm sitting you shouldn't be
at her on your own let's see
what's your name
why
fair enough
so what's your name
I understand it's not easy to
trust a couple of strangers
it's hard to trust strangers I know but
I honestly mean you know harm
Let's see we make a pretty good team
we got lucky
I only look how to run out sooner or
later hmm look
lucky no no
such thing as luck
you see I believe
and everything happens for a reason
just leave his luck no I I believe
everything happens for a reason this
winner
that's been especially cruel
we didn't expect this winner to be so
cruel
nothing will grow
game's been hard to find
a few weeks back
I am
sent a group of men out
nearby Town look for food
so I sent four of our people to a nearby
town to to scavenge what they could
only a few came back
and only three of them came back
he said that the others had been
slaughtered
oh yeah crazy man
turns out he was murdered
by this crazy man
I get this he's crazy man traveling
a little girl and get this
that crazy man
was traveling with a little girl
you see
everything happens for a reason
everything happens for a reason no way
David I'm not gonna let it lower
a gun he is the one that killed Alec
couldn't she she didn't kill anybody
lower the gun now give her the medicine
the others won't be happy about this did
you bring the medicine
yeah but throw it to her David where the
[__] out of the way
we won't survive long out there
can't protect you
survive for long out there
I can protect you
I remember experiencing this for the
first time and my stomach dropped with
the turn this was the guy you just
bought side by side with and had now
inadvertently revealed yourself as being
one of the people that caused this town
so much torment now they've added in a
layer with the person Joel killed being
the father of the girl at the steakhouse
and they of course are supposed to
reflect Joel and Ellie we see how the
stories have changed too which y'all
being described as a crazy man whereas
we know from our side that they attack
them in the game we we never saw David
and James's side after the conversation
but here we can see the doubting him
resurfaced once more as David lets her
go now we returned back at the house and
again see things play out similar to how
they do in the game
Joe
move your arm
s
[Music]
here we go
Joe where the [__] do I put this
[Music]
you're gonna make it
all right
foreign
ly this was the moment that you learned
Joel was alive and he'd had a large part
of the game his Ali where you had no
idea what his fate was similar to the
game Ellie lies down with him and
whereas in that we could at the morning
to see David's forces coming in here we
cut to the town there's a lot of focus
given to the meat with people clearly
knowing what's going on but they keep it
to themselves because the truth's too
difficult to bear it's said to be
venison but whether that's actually true
or not is another thing entirely James
does talk about suppliers earlier in the
episode but we know from their
interactions that they use code with
each other they could all be lying to
themselves keeping their mind off it and
it can mirror the predatory behavior
with David but let me know what you
think below at this point David and
James arrived with the deer and you
could say that like David James because
they saved
bit of an English joke there and David
admits that they've found who killed
Alec and he ends up slapping his
daughter when she suggests killing them
it shows just how abusive that he is and
he tells the girl that he's her father
now entire town sits in silence and
allows it to happen I think it very much
shows the grip that he has over everyone
when things come out about figures like
this you'll often hear about how many
people were aware of what was going on
but they turned a blind eye to it it's
very much the idea that you don't have
to deal with something if you ignorant
to it and no matter how horrific it is
you can reassure yourself that
everything is okay the reason I question
this venison is because this could very
much be carried over to the food too and
we get a lot of focus on the town's
people wolfing it down they're happy to
just tuck into their food have a warm
meal and be quiet because speaking UPS
better than starving I would then jump
back to Ellie and see as Joe looks
slightly better she injects him once
more and we get a slight differentiation
from the game as Ellie gets to go
outside whereas in the game she spotted
people coming in from the basement we
get a great scene with David and James
with the former clearly wanting to take
it even though it will only cause
problems with people back in their
Community David wants to spare her
because he has ulterior motives whereas
James sees it as being God's will that
they should leave her to die this very
much reflects Kathleen from earlier in
the season who believed it was Sam's
fatadai instead of getting the leukemia
medicine either way in both versions Ali
decides to head out and draw them away
with us getting a big action scene Ellie
leaves Joel with a knife and this is
what he later uses to interrogate the
people with in the game Ellie took her
horse and Road through the streets as
the hunter slept out to grab her and
eventually the horse was shot and she
fell down a Cliffside she then navigated
the surroundings and got into a hotel
which is where she tried to escape here
she stealthily took out hunters and
eventually was grabbed by David which is
when she was transported the camp yeah
they keep the sort of energy the same
but shorten things a bit with Ellie
riding out and the horse getting shot by
James David demands that Ellie is taken
and alive and I did find it interesting
how he mirrors Kathleen
Ernie for Revenge led to him making dumb
decisions and David's need to have Ali
leads to him doing the same thing he
stops Sally from being shot and even
carries her away similar to how giol
carried Sarah at the start of the season
the sick and twisted Father Figure is
pretty much a reverse Joel and he's
arguably the most dangerous person we
encounter in the whole show now it's uh
that's outside of one of the other
characters but moving on I'm in the game
one Sally is captured we then switch
perspectives to see Joe like what we get
here when he first took control you were
stumbling about and a little worse for
wear which is like how he appears here
too attention from the scene comes from
the fact that Joel is almost out of it
but he manages to get the upper hand and
take down David's men now the death
scene here is terrifying with a lot of
the struggles feeling like they're
ripped right out of the game the facial
expressions especially are something
that I always spin the camera around to
see and I guess we've discovered that
I'm a bit of a psychopath but please
subscribe and from here we get the
interrogation scene I was so happy
seeing this playing out as I was
thinking that the scene with Graeme
green was gonna be the show's version of
it might have spoiled the scene for you
if you watched our breakdown down for
that episode but I genuinely thought
that's how they were going to play it
the Disney the Disney interrogation was
how I thought they were going to play
this scene now because they're so
similar you might be asking why have
they done something that's basically the
same scene as that well it's for a good
reason as yeah we're seeing the true
side of Joel when Ellie's not around in
the cabin we knew nothing was gonna
happen as did the couple because there
was a little girl here they were likely
aware Joel wouldn't do anything which is
why they ended up laughing yeah though
Joel is free to do what he wants and
he'll do whatever he wants to get Ali
back now let's play the scenes from the
game and show you how Stuff lines up oh
leave him alone
ah
please I don't know any girl is she
alive what girl
I don't know no girl
oh Jesus
[__] Focus right here right here
not popping goddamn knee off you focused
kneecap off
the girl
she's alive she's alive
where
the town ah the town what town
Silver Lake
to where we are
and where your Resort is
and it better be the same exact spot
your buddy points to and it better be
the exact same spot your buddy points
too Market
right there
you can verify it go ask him go ask him
he'll tell you I'm not lying
I ain't telling you [__]
it's okay I believe him no all right so
let's do [__]
that's all right
I believe him no wait we also get a
follow-up from this with Ellie and a
moment that builds upon the original
I know you're hungry
been out for quite some time
[Applause]
what is it
it's deer what it's worth this is just
dear meat I swear it's just the deer
meat
[__] animals
you're gonna chop me up into little
pieces so now what
you're gonna chop me up into tiny pieces
I'd rather not
please just tell me your name please
tell me your name
you're so full of [__]
if you want to judge me judge you you're
gonna eat it
it's awfully quick to judgment
considering you and your friend killed
how many men the only way I'm going to
be able to convince the others
kind of been some of what that you can
come around
you have heart
you're loyal
and you're special
smart
loyal
oh
in the life we could build
faster
oh
[__]
stupid little girl
you little cut
what am I supposed to tell the others
now
let's see when I go tell the others now
Ellie
what Ally
what
tell them that
Ellie is the little girl
tell them that Ellie is a little girl
who broke her [__] finger
broke your [__] finger
how did you put it
tiny pieces
how did you put it hmm
tiny little pieces Ellie realizing that
cannonballs is so chilling because they
missed steak and it was a mistake
getting Ellie caged like this his
picturesque Last Resort on the world has
turned into something where people have
turned to cannibalism as a last resort
and what did the frustrated cannibal do
he threw up his hands
David recognizes the violent Hall with
an Ali and he even talks about how
cordyceps showed him the truth of the
world it feeds and protects its children
and he thinks that it actually loves I
realize at this point that the religion
things are charad and that he lets
others believe it because it brings them
Comfort however it also brings people
closer to him and though he won't admit
it it allows him to be propped up and
the cordyceps loving is something that
the show's creditors have talked about
on the podcast and even said that they
had the kiss with tears to hammer harm
this idea love is a lace throughout
every aspect of the show and we've seen
both the positives and negatives of it
you have people like Bill and Frank and
the coupling episode 6 but then you have
people like Kathleen and geol who it
just causes pain for David has a sick
and twisted kind of love and when he's
assaulting Ellie later on he creepily
says don't be afraid there's no fear in
love now the cordyceps are very much
made him believe that his sick and
twisted be of the world is the right one
and it's a chilling way to betray the
character although his plan with Ali
fails it's likely that he would have got
her into the camp had things not gonna
write everyone was just silent about him
I doubt they would have spoken up and
thus he probably could have got her as
one of the members taking out chill
would have helped him because he was the
only person defending him and I doubt
the other villagers would have been like
yeah Ellie's my friend especially after
this stuff for the University thus Ellie
would have been alone and what people
tend to do in abusive relationships is
that they get people away from their
friends and family thus they have no one
to fall back on and with his safety gun
they can fully manipulate the person and
control every aspect of their life now
back with Joe we see as the storm rolls
in and he makes his way to Salt Lake
this is a similar thing to the game and
at this point you're able to mask your
movements by using the environment now
inside a Hut there he discovers
belongings and bodies hanging up which
is similar to what happens when you
enter one in the game you find Ellie's
backpack which is ripped right out of it
too and he realizes just how much
trouble she's in the episode in general
it reminded me a lot of the movie the
road and which characters also come
across cannibals in that also it's
important to bear in mind that James is
comfortable doing this with the chopping
board probably because he's helped David
kill people like this before in the game
he even refers to Alias David's new pad
showing how he views her and we then get
Ali's Escape in another scene that's
ripped right out of the game
stop
I warned you
yeah
you had your chance
I'm infected
really
so are you
sorry really
roll up my sleeve look at it
look at it
[Music]
right there rolling my sleeve
look at it
what'd you say what did you say
three reason
everything happens for a reason right
what the hell is that now she would have
turned by now this isn't real okay what
a turn by now it can't be real looks
pretty [__] real to me it looks
pretty [__] real to me
[Music]
now you might be asking whether Ellie
biting someone can actually infect them
and there's a bit in the second game
that clears this up I'll talk about that
in the super spoiler section section
section well we do kind of know the
answer to it either way they cut the
sections down here and compressed the
scene so that Ellie goes immediately
into the restaurant in the game he made
your way through the town and jumped
back and forth between Joel and Ellie I
think it's actually smarter to handle it
like this and we see Ellie throwing a
burning log which ends up setting the
place on fire in the game as he went to
escape David grabbed you and eventually
this knocked over a lamp which then
started the Blaze and several lines in
the game are pulled directly across here
there's no way out Ellie
the doors are locked and I have the keys
nowhere to go
you want out
God has to come get these keys now Ali
burning down this quote-unquote church
also symbolically shows how she's
burning down the facade of everything
David spelled the pair battle it out
with one another and the struggle ends
up being exactly like how it is in the
game
[Music]
let me tell you something you have no
idea
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
stop stop
it's me it's me
[Music]
it's me
yeah
[Music]
oh baby girl
oh
[Music]
okay
it's okay baby girl
[Music]
during David's death we keep the focus
on Ellie and it shows how much Overkill
she's giving to this wicked and evil man
shall Comforts her and we get a really
important line dropped here where he
calls her baby girl this is the same
nickname that he gave to Sarah and at
this point he's all in on this being his
daughter the pair walk off together with
his arm around her and this is a
complete opposite to how they were in
episode 2. after Tessa's death Jill
stormed away leaving Ali Raz here we see
them closer than they've ever been the
pair have bonded over everything and
whereas she once was just cargo here
he's putting a coat around her to let
her know everything's okay and that
closes out the episode and we once more
get a shot of the pair walking away this
is imagery that's often used in the
shown game and it stages the characters
are going on the next part of their
journey and before we get into the
spoiler section I'll give my review and
I thought this episode was really solid
with some great performances in it Scott
Shepard brought a lot to David and that
points he was even creepier than Nolan
North in the game Things Are are a lot
more implied but there was some extra
lines of dialogue that they added which
really freaked me out now it was also
really nice seeing Troy Baker 2 and he
gave a lot away from just minor facial
expressions guy looked completely beaten
up at points and his Meek performance
made me think that he very much
represented the town's citizens who
refused to confront David I think this
episode worked really well as an
evolution of Ellie as well and it's no
coincidence that this is the chapter in
the game where you first take control of
her like that section this is very much
about her having to fight to survive
without help from others so far she's
relied on people like Federer Riley
Marlene Joel Tess and Henry and Sam but
this is her showing that when she's
cornered she can handle things that come
her way you also see that the character
is realizing that this world isn't as
fun as its cracked up to be going back
to that opening in episode 3 we've seen
how she thought wielding a gun with
something cool and also exciting here
though we have her smashing David's head
and like it's a like button and we see
the Relentless anger that she carries
huge change in Dynamic and her growth as
a character now as for what I didn't
like you already know what I'm gonna say
and I think the show has continued to
under use the infected which has taken
away from some of the most memorable
scenes of the game I think if we had
something with David where they had to
fight some of them it would have made
that turn as impactful as it is in the
game and with the episode just being 45
minutes long I think we could have
easily have gotten another 10 or even
five minutes where we had something like
that play out I'm guessing that they
pulled back on shonie in fact it is much
because of the budget but every week it
seems like there's a major moment
involving them which is left on The
Cutting Room floor minor nitpick and
yeah obviously the game's there if you
want to see more of them but I did kind
of want an action scene like that with
Ellie so we could see what she was
capable of against humans and also the
infected and that takes us into the
Super spoiler section and for the next
part of the video I want to go over some
of the Easter eggs that will probably
give the game away if you don't want
things spoiled then thanks for watching
thanks a lot mate again for wasting 40
minutes of your life and I hope to see
you back for the finale next week now
the first thing I want to talk about is
the interrogation technique in part two
aliors ends up using this and we of
course needed to see her actually see it
by herself in order to explain how she
knows this you also discover that Silver
Lake is a resort rather than just being
a town I wonder if this line was thrown
to show how Resorts have changed across
the country as part 2 ends with Ellie
going to a resort on the hunt for Abby
this was controlled by slavers and you
can see how these holiday locations have
been Twisted in this new world now
lastly is Ellie buying David was he
infected was he not we don't fully know
however Ellie does end up kissing Dino
in the second game and at one point she
also bites Abby when she's buying her in
the theater as we know Abby doesn't get
infected and thus I don't think that
Ellie's bite actually could infect
people infection seems to have stopped
at her arm and not made its way to her
saliva glands unless I don't think she
passes it on so I don't think early
actually infected David and either she
didn't know or she used it as a weapon
throughout the series she's been told to
hide it from people but she pulls her
down this moment to further slow down
confusion this throws James off a bit
and it adds upon what he was
experiencing before allowing Ali to
escape anyway that wraps up the video
and huge thank you for sticking with me
until the end I know I made a joke about
before but asking you guys to sometimes
give up 40 minutes of your life to watch
these things is a big ask and I
appreciate you for sticking with me
through it hopefully you've enjoyed the
video and now I'd love to hear your
thoughts on it in the comment section
below we are running a competition right
now giving away three copies of the
rocky 4K boxer on the 15th of March and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode we pick the comments out
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now similar to you then message me
on Twitter at heavy spoilers you don't
smells to watch it will cut a very
controversial video on screen right now
can we forgive Abby definitely go head
over there after this uh if you're
watching this part of the video you know
what I'm talking about in that spoiler
section you'd have to go head over right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video that'll be
important I'll see you next time take
care peace